we are very excited to present two
programs that we would have next year in
the fall of 20 and 21
we are going to present our
preschool center first this program is
very interesting because we would have three
classes of 16 students each class with
three teachers this program is
interesting  because it also has an
inclusive education component
so parents who have children who
have special needs can
come to our program our
program is open to the entire
community and also students and
also the nba faculty from college
the other program is our bachelor's degree
in early childhood education and
also special education it is a double
degree so students who
come to this program can earn
two degrees it is the only one of its
kind in the state in two programs we are going
to use various things for
various types of technology for example
the students of tacho saved or as
digam  os bachelors program will have
opportunities to learn how to use
science technology in gender and
math
that is very interesting across at
the center students will have
opportunities to observe our
nc students yes will have
opportunities to observe the children at
the center so
these are both  very interesting that
our students will
also have opportunities the students
the children of the center the families of the
center will also have access to this
technology this preschool education center
is interesting because
we also have an inclusive education component
that is very important because it
is a great need  in the
bada now so parents with children who
have special needs can
participate in this program but also
parents who for all who want
a high quality education there is a
movement now in the state to
prepare more children from birth
to 8 years old  and this program  This has not been
done, so there are many people who
do not have their children in a program,
our program is for the community,
but also our degree and it
also
helps the community, so in two hands it is
a help to our community, nothing
for us.  It is very important to have
collaborations with the district and also
because since this program is a
special education program and also
an early childhood program it
helps both sides also this time we will be
working
with teachers from the district community
because our students will have
time  and experiences and practices to
be in the class with teachers in the
district so for our
degree this is very important for
the center and we are going to have 16 students
for each class we would have three classes
for our degree the degree program
maybe we expected to have  20
students entering this program in
the fall so if there is anyone who is
i  Interested in being an
early childhood teacher and also in special education,
this program is for them the
bachelor's degree that we would have is one
in early childhood and also with an
inclusive education focus, so it is
the only thing in statues like this, it is
specifically at the level  stated
so we are very excited to
have this program what we are
doing here at college levels is
for the whole community not of these two
programs the first one the
preschool is for the
community again if there are students
that there are
special needs for  families who
need support but it is also for
everyone who wants a
quality education for their families the
dual degree program is another opportunity
to have more teachers and 20 teachers what
we need much less the state of
nevada